le détecteur d'hydrogène sulfuré ne
cesse de sonner et parfois sur ce
chantier
le taux grimpe jusqu'à 40 ppm un enfer
pour les riverains de cosmi c'est comme
si je dirais c'est la can nous quand
vous voyez qui envoie la cendre et ben
ça même chose et le gaz fédé grèce salue
les murs ça noirci les murs on est on en
a faite avec cette odeur
mais il n'ya pas que des riverains de
trinité qui attendent l'arrivée du
préfet des habitants du françois
ainsi que l'association protection
nature environnement le guette
ils veulent des réponses précises
évacuation était prévu alors à une seule
reprise pour répondre à votre question
si les taux atteignaient
des valeurs très élevées ou si on avait
des pathologies graves
alors je dis pas qu'on a pas de
pathologie vous le savez mieux que moi
le fait est qu'on n'a pas eu
d'hospitalisation préoccupante et c'est
ce dont s'occupe la halle agences
régionales de santé des riverains très
inquiets pour leur santé
un enlèvement des sargasses
particulièrement compliqué dangereux sur
le terrain et des mères qui réclame des
moyens pour protéger leurs populations
le préfet représentant de l'état face à
cette crise majeure est aujourd'hui dans
l'urgence
le phénomène est d'ampleur et donc je
suis venu aussi me rendre compte sur le
terrain des difficultés d'intervention
vous avez vu ce matin ces jeunes n'ont
pas pu intervenir à pied parce que les
trous des taux d'hydrogène sulfuré était
trop élevé et une seule les engins
pouvait intervenir la martinique dispose
aujourd'hui de 700000 euros pour
l'enlèvement des sargasses dans toutes
les communes insuffisant cris les
parlementaires et les maires avec ce que
l'on voit sur l'ensemble de la
martinique on voit tout au moins les
communes qui sont impactés par la somme
des sargasses c'est une enveloppe
insuffisante parce que quand on va
commencer à donner un peu à chaque
commune bien sûr qu'on va donner ne sera
pas suffisant pour être efficace tout de
suite je crois qu'actuellement le sujet
est moins un problème de mobilisation de
l'argent que de capacité d'intervenir
dans les 24 48 heures lorsque les
sargasses arrive pour les retirer tout
de suite de la plage avant de la plage
ou décotes avant qu'elles ne deviennent
dangereuses pour la santé humaine
mais ce que souhaitent les mères c'est
avant tout des moyens pour l'enlèvement
des sargasses en mer selon les autorités
les choses pourraient se compliquer dans
les prochaines semaines des bancs de
sargasses particulièrement importants
ont été repérés au large